hello everyone thank you for being here
we are the stem visualizations team and
we created an online pedagogical tool
for data science utilizing bokeh
so just for a quick introduction to our
team we're all students at lehigh
university in our junior year i am neil
and today i'm joined by my teammates
timothy and shu we also have two key
advisors who have helped us along the
way and those are dr ragharam
thiagarajan and professor srinivas
rangarajan of the department of chemical
and biomolecular engineering we've also
had external help in the form of steve
anthony of the lehigh university
technology services and all late
professor vincent grassi also the
department of chemical and biomolecular
engineering
so there are four key things that cause
us to start our mission of building
interactive visualizations to teach
topics in science and engineering the
first one is the kovid 19 pandemic
students during this time really lack
the interactive experience that is so
strongly needed in stem education the
second issue is the stem retention rate
anecdotally and from actual evidence
students have trouble understanding
complex stem topics due to mundane and
traditional teaching styles the third
issue is the stem dropout rate dropper
rates are high in my opinion due to the
inability to properly engage students
and the final issue is the lack of
resources outside the classroom without
proper supplementary resources students
interests in these topics lean outside
the classroom
so here's a quick introduction to our
current repository of visualizations on
the far left here we have a reaction
kinetics model right next to it we have
our scir infectious disease model and on
the far right we have our zero energy
cooling chamber model in the middle here
we have our data science model which is
what we're going to be focusing this
talk on today
so before we get into the details of the
data science model we want to talk a
little bit about inquiry-based learning
a key of all our models is to promote
this type of learning and for those of
you not aware what inquiry-based
learning is is an active form of
learning where questions and scenarios
are posed first some of the benefits of
this type of learning include it
promotes a deeper understanding of
content it provides a new fun and
engaging way to learn and to build
initiative and self-direction in
students so to really test out if our
models exhibited inquiry-based learning
we conducted a formative assessment of a
group of freshmen at lehigh we're taking
an introductory engineering course where
the zero energy cooling chamber model
was utilized one of the key questions we
asked was are learning these concepts
through the model we built a more
effective way to learn if it's simply
reading a textbook or listening to a
traditional lecture we received a strong
average of 8.75 out of 10 on that
question and the second key question we
asked was inquiry-based learning is a
technique which promotes active learning
through posing questions scenarios are
problems how well does our model promote
this technique we also received a strong
average of 8.25 out of 10 on that
so before we begin to show our model
let's talk about what what the data set
entails the dataset that we're using is
a catalysis dataset in which we're
trying to
see how how these catalysts improve the
reaction time and reaction rate
and then within that data set we have
different input features
such as the the the oxygen flow methane
flow
the temperature
and the conversion rates and then we
have the products that are that come
about from
from these from these reactions that are
taking place like the the carbon that
has produced and other and other things
so this is a video of
of of the model so basically we have the
model description
we have the model description first and
then we have a data exploration sampling
the user and they'll play around with
the data and see how the
how the different features interact with
one another
now we have a correlation matrix just to
help the user see how the different
values relate to each other and we added
color for more interactivity
and we have a multivariable regression
model in which the user can select
different features to build the model
and to predict a particular
y value or a product that is being made
so we we have the the quotients of the
variables on the side we have the r the
r square squares and the rmse scores on
the left as well
and then the user can then pick what
kind of model they want if is linear
quadratic or cubic
and below we also have
and we've divided that into training and
testing to see how well they work
together and we have an error histogram
at the bottom
yeah but also provides learning model in
which the user can pick different number
of clusters that they want and then
number of principal components that they
want to
to test their data on
so this this just continues calculating
the the importance of the different
variables in this in this
and then we have a classification model
in which we want to
in which we want to predict
which
how much how much carbon will be formed
at the end of each one of them
all right
in order to create the interactive data
science
model we utilize 4k to generate the web
web application
the whole process is a loop that we
first select the data by filtering the
empty data point and then let the user
to choose
choose which dataset
they want to include in the module
calculation
cycle learning is a library that
provides most of the data science
algorithm
so we can use
the circuit we can change the train and
build the model
by the using the function improvise
but create is a firmware that translates
python called into html since our
initial goal is to create a web
application we use functions such as
clouds and tabs to lay out all the
components we need
after improving the module this process
will keep going whenever the user
changes their attributes
and this is the workflow
of the regression model um
we were utilizing the attributes from
datasets to create this model first the
cleaning will remove all the empty data
points and then we decided uh the kinds
of
selected selection tools we need for the
user
since this multivariate regression model
multiple x values can be selected
so methane flow temperature and total
flow are the most important attributes
in this case because when the users
select
those attributes they will see relative
better scores
the data set will then be divided into
chaining and testing data sets
and we will use the training set to
build a model and calculate the scores
after getting all the necessary data
points we will use bokeh to to set up
the plot table
error histogram and the line indicators
by looking at the scores and plots the
user can decide whether to accept or
rerun the
selection process again
after that we have a classification
model in which we we
classify if if the catalyst that we're
using is a good or bad catalyst
according to the carbon selectivity that
we get from the product
so firstly we create a classifier in
which
we we check if the carbon selectivity is
either above 40 or below 40 and then we
sample the data set by like to 40 of it
and we select the target variable
and then we create controls for the user
select what whichever feature they want
to put into the reaction so the
so they can choose either the
temperature
the methane flow the oxygen flow or or
any other feature
and then with that information given the
we divide the divided into training and
testing sets and then we create the
model using cycler
and then we plot the graphs and then we
generate the confusion matrix which will
basically
count how many how many of these how
many of these were
were made
were selected correctly in the right in
the right bracket and now we calculate
the evaluation matrix metrics which
include
which include the accuracy the f measure
the recall and others
okay our goal is to create interactive
web application for stem students we are
currently in the process of getting all
feedbacks on the data science model we
just created and we want to use the
feedback to make our application to be
more friendly user friendly
as some models on the website such as
xero energy current chamber module
was already integrated in the intro to
engineering courses our next step is to
make more visualization
wanted in more innovative topics to help
the students in stem field to visualize
the concept they were doing costs
so thank you so much for listening to
our talk um we'd like to acknowledge the
office of creative inquiry at the
university provides funding and guidance
throughout this project and then also
the national science foundation for
inspiration thank you so much and we're
happy to answer any questions you have
thank you thank you neil timothy uh
for delivering the wagon talk i think we
are we are almost at the time so we'll
you can take your questions over at the
slack
uh do we have logan here
yes hey everyone awesome wonderful um i
appreciate the the icebreaker and how's
it going everyone my name is logan
kilpatrick i'm the community manager for
the julia programming language i'm also
on the the board of directors here at
num focus so really excited about this
talk and i think this is something that
i'm i'm super passionate about uh and
the the sort of general topic for for
today's talk is around non-code
contributions sort of non-technical
contributions in open source why they're
important how to enable them in your own
specific scientific or open source
package uh community and uh let's let's
dive in and talk about some of these
things
so one of my one of my favorite quotes
and at some point this will turn into a
t-shirt is that uh there's more to open
source than code and i think for a lot
of us uh at least speaking from my own
experience i think there's lots of
i'm sure technical folks here who have
sort of done a lot of technical work in
the open source space so you know
you know when you think about open
source the first thing you think about
is okay i'm going to open pull requests
i'm going to commit code i'm going to
you know do all these deeply technical
things
and i think for for first time
contributors for new members of
communities that's oftentimes
you know some of those specific
mechanisms to contribute to open source
are a little bit more difficult to
tackle you know right the beginning of
your open source journey and
again throughout this talk i'll sort of
make the high-level argument that um
setting up these sort of contribution
pathways for folks who who maybe aren't
ready to dive in and make a pull request
or a code contribution um will be
helpful for your for your specific
ecosystem and community
so when we talk about okay so you know
someone is perhaps not ready to to make
a code contribution or perhaps doesn't
want to make a code contribution what
are the some of the the sort of other
ways in which somebody can make
contributions to an open source project
and i think you know i've i've tried to
highlight a few of them here on the
screen some of these things can be you
know helping out with social media
outreach outreach i think you know for a
lot of open source projects um you know
they it's it's something that could
potentially be neglected if they don't
have somebody who's in that role sort of
doing this outreach responding to people
on social media
all that stuff and at the end of the day
you know that might be the way in which
new contributors come into your project
as they they see something on social
media and they decide hey maybe i want
to go and contribute to to numpy or
whatever it is um so i think that's one
possible option for folks who are
interested in getting started um
blogging is a huge one if you're like
hey i'm not ready to make a code
contribution perhaps just
you know try out some tutorials uh you
know write a use case something really
simple and share with other people and i
think not only is that good for the
project because they're getting exposure
they're to have a user who's advocating
for them
but for the person who's actually doing
that it's an important step as well
because i i think and it's just like
giving a talk um you know it's it's
really difficult to sort of formalize
whatever your thought is until you've
had to put it to spoken word or put it
to written word so i think both of those
options are really um you know
beneficial for the person who's actually
giving that uh writing that blog post
another one that i think is perhaps
flying under the radar a little bit and
i'll just talk about it for a moment
because it's something that i've
personally done
is posting questions on stack overflow i
think a lot of the times people
you know and it's not specific to stack
overflow any q a platform but sort of
finding out what pain points are for
people who are users of your specific
software and going in asking those
questions if you know what the issues
are you know what the pain points are
going and asking those questions on a
platform like stack overflow or
discourse
and then answering those questions
yourself if you can find the answer
will actually make it so that hey the
next person who comes along they don't
have to post in some channel or they
don't have to take the time to post they
can just go and find the answer to
whatever their problem is right away i
think that's a super impactful way of
contributing to open source that again
isn't
isn't going to show up on your your
github profile activity uh necessarily
so again hopefully this sort of lays the
the groundwork for you know what some of
these possible contribution uh pathways
might be for somebody and again i've
talked about this notion of a
contribution pathway a few times but
what does that actually look like and
again i sort of conceptualized this this
arc of contributing and the last stage
in this arc of being a contributor in
open source is the code contribution and
again if you're an experienced developer
your experience in open source perhaps
you can sort of dive right into that
depending on the project your
familiarity and all those things but i
think presenting this this idea to new
contributors that hey the expectation
isn't that you're going to come in and
sort of solve some deep concurrency
problem in a
well-known python package as your first
contribution like that's totally okay
that's that's not the expectation that
we need to set for contributors um and
and setting the expectation that hey you
can take all these smaller steps and
then eventually maybe you go through
those smaller steps a few times and then
finally make a code contribution i think
this is a super important idea to to
reinforce to people
and again i think this this sort of
highlights the idea that
the the developers in open source
aren't necessarily the only people um
that that are important to the ecosystem
you have people who are sort of running
things perhaps a little bit more from
behind the scenes you have release
managers who perhaps aren't
necessarily contributing new features
but helping orchestrate you know some of
the higher level logistics of making
sure that all the features that other
people have written actually get
released in a reliable and meaningful
way so there's there's lots of different
roles sort of in the open source
community in space and i think
keeping that in mind as you as you push
forward in your own open source uh
journey is important
so again thinking about how from a
community standpoint from a maintainer
standpoint from a actual contributor
standpoint are these open source
contributions going to come back and
actually impact the community and also
your own personal journey i think
there's a there's a few different pieces
again a lot of the sort of underlying uh
trend behind all these sort of
non-technical non-code contributions
that i've mentioned so far is in the
realm of communication communicating
ideas to folks probably technical ideas
because it's
because it's open source but i think
that's such an impactful
uh impactful thing to learn about and
experience to have and again if you're
sort of just in the beginning of the the
sort of open source journey
or perhaps trying to attract people to
your project who are just in the
beginning of that open source journey
you know talking about the benefits of
being an effective communicator
especially in technical topics i think
is one of the most important things that
you can do um again this idea of
building bridges within the community a
lot of times in open source you have
sort of these these fragmented technical
communities that sort of interact with
each other in some capacities and um i
think
the idea of you know using communication
using all these non-technical
contribution pathways to sort of layer
these bridges on top of all these
different sub technical communities is
is the way that i think about this um
actually materializing and the last
piece is sort of broadening your own
skill perhaps again maybe you have the
technical skills maybe you can go and
make the technical contribution but you
want to perhaps try something else out
so you can develop that that other skill
set that broader skill set
so maybe you've been convinced that this
is worthwhile to get started on um so
thinking about from a from a maintainer
standpoint and also from a from a
contributor standpoint how can you
actually get started so i'll talk really
quickly from a contributor standpoint
reach out to people if you're already
part of a specific community some uh
perhaps one of the one of the
non-focused projects you're already
within that community
reach out to people who you see doing
the work already to whether it's
maintainers what have you say hey here's
some specific idea of a way that i'd
like to contribute how can i go ahead
and get involved in that capacity
the other way to do it is what i would
consider the permissionless approach
which is just go and do stuff if there's
an article that you think would be
helpful go and write the article
if there's some other contribution you
think would be impactful make that
contribution then go and tell other
people about it and i think in general
people tend to be very
very happy that you've made that
contribution
again for for folks who are maintainers
i would suggest taking a look at
julialang.org contribute we're doing a
lot of work there
um sort of laying out the high level
structure of this message that we want
to tell people when they come to the
julia community which is hey you can
contribute to the julia community
without having to make some deep
technical contribution
so that's something that i'll refer
folks to to check out and
again the idea here is hopefully that
you can help sort of fill those gaps
build those bridges in your own
community and um i'm super glad i got to
share this all if any of this is
interesting questions shoot me an email
always happy to chat about it
awesome
uh thank you thank you for your time uh
do we have nick with us yeah right here
yeah awesome all right so i'm nick
agarwal i'm a director of data science
at make you safe and i'm also an adjunct
instructor at university of
wisconsin-madison and so today i'll be
talking a little bit about how i use
both arm python and my workflow today
and all from within r so
not having to go into like a python ide
in any way but just using rstudio and r
and then also leveraging python
libraries within it so
some of the stems from
my my work where some of my team members
some of them are python coders some of
them are our coders and really there's
been healthy discussions about r versus
python and while it's enjoyable to see
this conflict happen sometimes some of
those points that are erased are
somewhat meaningful but mostly the
conversations i feel are not really
useful in any way
because to me it doesn't really matter
which language you use whether it's r
python julia c as long as the tool that
you're using is effective and languages
to me are essentially tools and if they
can help you answer the business
questions that you're trying to solve
for then it then it works
and
sometimes as data scientists or even
data analysts or data professionals on
my team the issue becomes like oh if
we're going to deploy this then do i
need to do this in one specific language
so a lot of my team members are in r and
so they feel like well if we're going to
deploy this in python or if we have
somebody develop something in python do
we have to use all use python for this
project and the answer the short answer
for that is really no you don't have to
because not all of our models will go
into production but at the same time if
they will go into production we really
think about how do we want to deploy
them and it doesn't really matter
whether it's going to be an r or python
and we want to move away from that
and often we find that some libraries in
certain languages are actually easier to
use or more fun to use whichever way so
me personally like i really enjoy using
ggplot2 and r and i don't enjoy
matplotlib as much does that mean the
map plot lives back no not really it
just means that i'm not as effective
with matplotlib than as i am with
ggplot2 and so if i'm doing data
analysis and data modeling in a script
if i want to use ggplot2 and i also want
to use python
like
scikit-learn or sklearn how do i do that
and it's always been challenging before
what i'm going to talk about this
package
that i'm using before that it would be
i'd have to do some work in rstudio and
horton r and then save my work and
export data out and then move into vs
code or some other id for python and
then go from there
so
reticulate is a solution to that now i'm
not the developer of articulate so
please don't blame me for anything or
ask me questions about how articulate
works in the inner workings of it but
reticulate is a package in r developed
by our studio and it really allows you
to use a lot of python libraries from
within r and using our syntax so you
really get the best of both worlds so if
there's libraries and python that you
want to use or you feel like you want to
develop models and python you can go
ahead and use r for a lot of your work
and including importing those libraries
from python into r and then being able
to do that and what's really cool about
reticulate is that it's able to
translate a lot of the r objects and
python objects to each language really
much on the fly so if you have a data
frame in r it gets converted into a
pandas data frame in python and then you
can move forward from there and that
makes the workflow really fun because
then you can use whichever tools you
want from whichever language and really
supplement your work to be even more
effective than before
so as i mentioned you can use any
library you want and what's interesting
is that one thing i want to point out is
if you use the keras library in r it's
actually using reticulate as well in the
background and it's using and it's
leveraging python as well already so
it's really cool to that if you're using
kerasnr you're already using it and so
you may not realize it all the way and
the best part is that if my team can
then maintain that workflow in r so they
can do all their work so whether it's
data analysis or data preparation and
whatnot
and so that brings me to my typical
workflow so i'm doing my data analysis
and ingesting information and whatnot
it's coming in from r and i can use r to
read in the data to go ahead and plot it
do my exploratory data analysis and even
do some cool statistical tests and what
not all in r but then when it comes to
data modeling i can then use both the
tidy model verse if i want to or i can
use sklearn or i can use pytorch or
whatever libraries i want in whatever
language but i can use them all from
within r and i don't have to worry about
knowing or having to move data from one
ide to another i can just say one id or
one script and just continue my workflow
in our organization
deployment for our models is typically
done in docker containers we like for r
we'll go ahead and use plumber and have
our packages internal our packages
developed and then we'll deploy from
there and in python we'll just use flask
and then deploy but again within doc
container and be able to scale from
there
so
this screenshot is just a quick example
a quick uh snapshot if you will of what
um of how the syntax looks like for
reticulate and particularly does try to
keep some of the nomenclature as
similar to what's in python as well so
for example when you have to import
libraries you can just go ahead and say
import and then the
library name and then also the sub
functions within that library and then
how to use them you can in within r you
can use the piping mechanism you can use
the dollar operator to find those other
components within that object and
continue on creating dictionaries on the
fly and also lists as what and whatnot
so it's really powerful tool and for
most of our purposes we've been able to
use reticulate very successfully in
being able to use both python libraries
and our libraries we don't really run
into any issues in terms of performance
what we found is that reticulate works
really well in fact we find that python
does a better job of parallelizing
certain operations and so we tend to use
those
python libraries for that for that as
well and particularly can respect that
so
um and if you are a strictly python user
like some of some of my team members and
they really want to use some of the r
functions or our libraries there's our
pi 2. i don't have a lot of experience
with this but this is also a really cool
library that what my team team teammates
have shown me and how they use it and it
really is really interesting how it
works it's very similar to articulate
but it works the other way around you
start with python and you can use your r
libraries and r functions from within
python and
so i just have a few resources to share
with you i have an example of a full
kind of like a detailed more detailed
example of how i use reticulate and just
kind of a walk through
uh link to art by two and then also a
link to this presentation and also a way
to contact me if you have any questions
i know this is a really brief
presentation really quick one but the
goal here being that i just want to give
you a small flavor of what articulate
can do and how it works for us and how
we use it and why we love using
reticulate within within r and how we
use the best of both worlds thank you
yeah thank you nick i see a question in
the chat
reticulate versus rpi which is better
um that's a good question um i find that
reticulate has a lot of better
documentation so if you're trying to
solve for a piece sorting into certain
issues and whatnot i find that it's
easier to troubleshoot the reticulate
side a little bit better and then then
rpi uh too but that's not to say that i
haven't done like i said i haven't done
a lot of work with rfi2 and my teammates
have and so they run into it but
generally uh from my experience
reticulate has really good documentation
and i can solve a lot of my issues that
i run into with just looking at the
github or the other documentation that's
out there
awesome
uh do we have ron with this
yes
so i'm just going to talk this way in
case i need to change something on the
fly um so this is uh
i would say what kind of different from
many other talks i have seen um
in this
pi data global so uh like first a quick
introduction myself uh my name is ron
i'm a business intelligence engineer at
uni 21. um we are anti-fraud uh like uh
anti-money laundering financial ins um
company based in um san francisco but i
personally work from los angeles
so um but before that i was a data
scientist at
galvanize which is a training
institution so to help people transfer
to the data science domain
so i this is my personal hobby project i
would like to share some of my discovery
topic is can the best language model
detect logical fallacies
the subtitles can help us become better
information absorbers i'll do some
definition first um well by the way i
will focus on the what and why question
rather than how because we probably
don't have enough time so let's talk
about the fantasy side so we i we can
classify the viruses
into two big groups the first part is
the so-called formal fallacies the
second part is informal fallacies the
thermophilalysis they are fallacies that
violate the logical structures or the
forms
of a statement for example um
if a is right then b is right okay this
is a fact we accept that then we say a
is wrong then we can say okay therefore
b is wrong this is not right it's not
right not because the facts it states is
not read or not because we have no
knowledge about that what we know is
that the form is wrong so here's another
example i say like all apples are spicy
well it's obviously not true but let's
accept it then i say i have an apple
therefore my apple is spicy then
like in terms of the form of this
statement it's true but in terms of fact
this the
soundness is false but we don't care so
this is called formal fallacy you can
essentially write some
how to say hardcode some rules for
computer to detect whether it's a
fallacy or not if you have a setup
through
like a prayer
informal pharisees they are a little bit
tricky that's why i come to the deep
learning for the rescue the informal
pharisees they're more they're wrong
about the content or the context for
example here is a typical violence it's
called strongman fallacy we often see
them
in political debates or advertisements
so i'm sorry
thanks don't tell us
so
say bob says i think pollution from
human contributes to climate change okay
this is a statement we don't know
whether it's true or not but artists can
say okay you think humans are directly
responsible for extreme weather
exaggerators there's a lot of stuff
alice can say
so this is like alice is attacking
something that bob does not claim
and that says obviously if that's the
case in which you need to go to this
house to perform a rain dance so that's
even like a
more uh extreme statement ideas like you
just uh um
bob just um doesn't answer ice doesn't
answer bob's statement directly however
we human will easily fall into those
fallacies and they wouldn't be able to
actually
detect those issues
the first time we saw that or we're just
being driven by the political like you
know the rhythm of the debates something
like that
so can we resolve this well probably
can't but we cannot do it manually if
you google like a informal files you
will see some websites that collect
those viruses but it's not possible to
build databases to
you know capture everything because
people create those kinds of stuff every
day then we turn to the language models
and they're super powerful everybody
knows that a bit of everybody in the
channel knows that in this
meeting so start with birds it's the
start of the new era it has about 100
mating parameters probably then on gp2
p3 and the latest we have the unreleased
model from google and i just searched
like five minutes ago it looks like
there is a next generation is like a 100
trading parameter language model well
it's like a the competition between um
like those model builders and the
federal reserve like just
putting up numbers
so
open ai like uh
they open source they're not open source
somehow they provide the uh gp3
available for the public to use so we
just take advantage of that to see
whether i can use its classification
like a
functionality to help me to detect
whether a statement contains
like an informal fallacy or not
all right
so i have
these three tasks to do the first task
is to collect a data set with ground
truths labeled unfortunately there is no
such database available so just
doing my own labor work collect those
sentences so that they there are two
choices to collect this um database data
set one choice is like uh
you have a pair of sentences uh one is
uh
talking about a
topic
um deliberately can that contains
information informal analysis then you
just talk it uh like how to say more
rigorously or scientifically
like you explicitly uh exclude the
existence of informal fallacies another
way is just you
collect the informal fallacies and just
some
other random sentences the second case
is more close to our
like a
daily life in real life but uh it will
make i'm i'm still trying to engage
which partition of those two parts
should i use in the data set the second
part is to perform some exploratory
tests on several kinds of informal
logical fallacies there are about 40 50
most common informal biological
fallacies and how does the performance
vary so
uh a
acknowledgement goes uh here you need to
go to arpuran like for his post on
medium because when i first started
working on this uh his article
is the only one on the internet that i
can find that talks about this concept
and i also talked to him on linkedin to
uh discuss this like
direction which i think is pretty fun
pretty interesting so the task two so i
frame the following tabs as a
classification questions so um if you
basically i don't use any api just to
use the playground on
openis website so you can uh provide
some training data not not essentially
training but like you can ask
openli to predict the the labeling of
the corresponding statements as you can
see this is what we we get typically you
can have yes to indicate whether that it
is a uh informal fallacy and no because
actually you can check the probabilities
so uh the
one lesson i learned is that you always
show the probabilities because sometimes
even the result is yes but it's just
slightly better than no then it doesn't
make too much sense so we have several
different one different different ones
so um here are some early finding i
would like to show you
so for some tabs the results seem to be
really nice for example strongman
fallacies can almost always get caught
and there is
no surprise because there is a intuition
there the intuition is that there are
essentially two different topics that
are discussed here is one like the
country should invite more in education
another person says oh what you want to
reduce the military budget to put our
country at the risk so military budget
education there are basically two
somehow neighboring concepts here being
discussed um the mod they open the eye
to
kind of capture this
like a contrast and show the uh rhythm
am i out of time
no okay then but for others not really
for example false dilemma is a typical
example the first therma well if you see
this you know what this foster number is
the either you are with us or you're
always a terrorist that's what uh before
like uh
say um afghanistan will break off like
president bush uh make a statement so
obviously this may not be true like you
can be neutral uh somehow uh it's it's
just a you know like a war cry but it's
false dilemma unfortunately um the
model will not be able to capture the
difference between this one and this one
i think the intuition here is like the
context is as lost if you just provide
the sentences um then
you know the post sounds like a strong
words in war troops terrorists um but
the ai does not understand exactly what
these sentences mean
okay
so here is potential direction i would
like to do the first one i just
mentioned that you can standardize the
data set
and there you can create two kinds of
data sets to see which one works better
and you can we somehow may want to print
our own model and uh just use the
pre-trained model and you know buy some
use some
very expensive gpus to um further
fine-tune that you can also uh like uh
use the fine-tune
like a functionality on on openis
platform at also possibility so one goal
like in the short term for me is i want
to create a browser extension for that
so whenever we browse
the news the analysis of what you watch
youtube's then somehow you can highlight
the sentences with a higher probability
that it contains informal logical
fallacy which probably will make us
better like a information observers and
thinkers
yeah that's it thanks
thank you ron uh do we have braden with
us
yeah yeah right here uh over to you
brilliant
great um
so hi everyone my name is braden riggs
i'm part of the dolby developer
relations team
um and i'm here to explore what i think
is an awesome topic which is uh
unlocking more insight from your audio
data
let's quickly speak about what dolby io
is and why i'm here dolby io is a
self-service platform that provides a
number of apis that allow developers to
build communications media and streaming
solutions for things like podcasting or
telehealth
and these apis come in like two flavors
like that we have our communications api
and then our media processing apis which
are kind of more relevant to pi data
now some of these media processing apis
cater towards my data science background
which is why i'm here talking about like
audio data
specifically our audio analysis apis
which can generate insight and create
data from raw audio and we'll kind of
get more onto that shortly but first
like
what is audio data and why should you be
interested in it well
sound as we perceive it is fundamentally
a series of vibrations passed through a
medium and interpreted by the ear
you can hear me now because the speakers
on your device compress air in such a
way that we can interpret it
now of course i'm not speaking in front
of you in person so between the step of
projecting and interpreting these air
vibrations is a computer where audio is
stored as a series of ones and zeros
when converting these air vibrations to
zeros and ones the computer needs to
sample the air pressure at a repeated
rate known as the sample rate which is
often 44.1 kilohertz or 44
100 samples per second
now additionally these samples are taken
at a resolution known as bit depth or
rather the number of bits stored per
sample commonly 16 bits
hence to store just one second of audio
at 44.1 kilohertz and 16-bit storage
requires 44 100 times 16 times one
second bits or if converted around 86
kilobytes
now additionally most audio is two
channels which doubles this figure and
some mediums are recorded uh at much
higher sample rates and bit depths
so who cares right
well for comparison a character is 8
bits
which means that the amount of storage
required for me to store my entire
script for this presentation
only requires about 2 kilobytes
so why is audio so much more storage
intensive it's because recording audio
captures much much more than just the
instrument or the voice speaking into
the microphone
and the mistake lots of beginners make
when analyzing let's say podcasts let's
say you're doing a podcast
research program a project is assuming
that getting like a transcription of the
audio like just the spoken words
is enough of the picture
and that's not to say that
transcriptions aren't useful as we'll
see later transcriptions are a great
addition to your data set
it's just that lots of tools or guides
you find on the internet just focus on
converting
that audio to text and then like perform
sentiment analysis on the text rather
than investigate the audio signals
themselves
but obviously like something is lost in
this conversion and so much data is
wasted
and that's the really exciting part
about audio data it's such an incredibly
rich data source with so much
information captured that we're really
only just beginning to uh scratch the
surface and utilize it in data science
for all that it's worth
great so we know what this audio data is
um but how do we use it and more
specifically like how do we use it
effectively well in the interest of time
i'm going to briefly touch on three
tools that can help you learn a little
bit more about the audio that you're
analyzing
our first tool is pi audio analysis
which is authored by theodorus
giganopolis
and the tool can be used for a variety
of signal processing related tasks
most notably like visualizing audio data
extracting audio features and performing
unsupervised segmentation
and you can see an example on screen
here of like kind of what these like
feature vectors look like that can
automatically generate from audio data
i really like pi audio analysis is like
a first pass tool to use on data sets um
like i'm just getting started with a
project and i want to use it to do a bit
of eda or to see if i can
classify or form some clusters in the
group it's a really great tool for that
stuff
the second tool is actually like two
tools wrapped into one
i like to use ms azure's cognitive
services speech-to-text tool to create a
transcript of the spoken words in my
audio data and natural language toolkit
to then analyze those words and perform
tasks such as like sentiment analysis
um and finally as mentioned earlier in
the deck dolby io uh provides a variety
of audio related tools however i
specifically want to focus on our
analyze audio and our analyze speech
tools
these tools provide a variety of
insights into the data based on the
audio signals itself
and specifically i want to focus on like
speaker and like music segmentation
examples
um the api takes the audio and separates
it into segments but you can kind of see
an example of the output there pictured
on screen
um and then once it's split into
segments they're like time stamps so you
know oh like this person is speaking at
this point and then another person is
speaking at this point
um
cool so like now with all three of these
tools let's look at an example of how we
can like leverage the power to
create like some stunning insights into
the world of podcasts um now why did i
choose podcasts well podcasts provide an
interesting mix of of music and like
intros and outros and speech sometimes
split among multiple speakers at
irregular intervals
not to mention that podcasts have
exploded in popularity in the last
couple of years
now i don't have time to go into the
full analysis but
here are a few highlights pictured on
screen is the relationship between
podcast popularity and downloads and the
percentage of audio defects in the
podcasts such as silence
now you can see a spike in popularity
that happens at episode 12
and this kind of correlates all of a
suddenly with like a change in the audio
quality of the podcast
now we can infer from this that maybe
with their newfound popularity they were
able to get sponsors and with sponsors
they were able to hire audio engineers
to uh
you know tweak their audio and improve
it and it's interesting that you can
kind of see that that correlation in the
data
we can also compare sports podcasts to
say like business podcasts uh to see the
signal related
differences i think we can agree like
sports and business are two very uh
contrasting genres so it's interesting
to see that this contrast is actually
reflected in the intensity of like each
episode with the red being like our
sports podcast episodes and the blue
being like our business episodes
and if we really want to dive in we can
look at speaker patterns across the
series pictured above is a speaker
picture above is each speaker that
occurs across this entire uh series of
podcasts
in this case it was uh 15 unique
speakers across like the whole series uh
and in what part of the opening 10
minutes that they spoke this is kind of
what we're looking at the brighter the
segment uh the more often they were
speaking on average so for example
speaker zero at the top typically spoke
within the first hundred seconds
with a few particularly bright segments
indicating that there was a pattern to
when he spoke
this is likely because he's the host of
the podcast he's introducing the podcast
each week
um and there's like a variety of guests
who kind of jump in or interject after
that
uh and these visuals are mainly just to
get you like thinking about some of the
cool applications of these
three tools and and their synergies and
how they can compare together to uh
maybe do some kind of out-of-the-box
stuff that you mightn't of uh
might not have thought of initially
great now of course this is just a
lightning talk so it's pretty brief and
i can't even scratch the surface of
everything i want to cover but i'm
excited to announce that we're giving a
full length version of this presentation
as a tutorial
this will be on saturday october 30th at
8 a.m u.s pacific time 5 p.m central
european time or midnight japan time
uh now of course time zones are a mess
so if you want a reminder i'll be
posting to my twitter linkedin before i
present so give me a follow i'd love to
see everybody here there
and of course if you're interested in
learning more about our apis you can
visit our event documentation
we'd love to get any feedback everybody
has and as many people to try out this
stuff as possible so thank you for
watching
oh thank you brian and uh there's one
thing i would like to mention so dolby
is one of the sponsors for paradigm
and i would uh like to thank you
dolby braden you and all the staff would
all be to supporting us because it
hasn't been possible without you and uh
yeah
thank you
so yeah uh
jacob we have jacob
okay hello everyone my name is jacob
zelko good morning good evening at night
wherever you are in the world so glad to
be talking to you i'm from georgia tech
research institute where i work as a
researcher and also as a contractor at
the centers for use control today my
talk is on a visual odyssey animations
and visualizations made with julia this
is me by myself and my co-creator ola
kroger and there are the list of our
maintainers
for the project
so to begin with we use a tool called
javas.jl which myself and ola have
created and javas.jl focuses on creating
an easy to use interface written in
julia to create visualizations and
animations javas is a tool for
exploration that gives users great
freedom and flexibility to a user for
whatever animations and purposes they
may have
it should go without saying that javas
is actually an animation engine it can
create objects render objects animate
objects and together it has all the main
functionality that comes together to
create an animation engine
here's an example of an animation
created with javas very simple
in javas we actually emphasize a object
and action relationship where
shapes such as square squares circles uh
are represented as objects and movements
like translations or the movements that
you see taking place in this animation
are defined as actions as you can see in
the bottom left these are some frames
from this particular gif where each
individual frame is generated almost
like a slide reel
and here's just some a very simple sim
well very basic syntax for how this
actually works you can see that an
object is being defined in an action
called animate rotate around is being
applied to the two objects we created
which are red and blue balls
this is as complex as we're going to get
to in this tutorial as i want to
emphasize more
the animation and visualization side of
this tool
so now it is time to jump over to some
demos
so first of all
uh
this animation was created by then
mayan and
very quickly i will run this animation
just in the background as i discuss it
but what this animation was
depicting is actually how you can use
javascript jl for specific domain
applications in this case we are using
it specifically for
modeling the rotation of venus and earth
around each other in space
and once that is done once this uh
animation is done being rendered
we actually will get to see
this animation and believe me i have
stared at this animation for way too
long so many times as you model the
orbits going around each other and this
is just one example to show how the
animations can actually be
used to highlight domain specific
problems in this case uh earth and venus
revolving around each other and the
reason why it's glitching a little bit
right now is because this file is being
executed in the background of visual
studio code code which is just one of
the many of the uh one of the many
integrations that javis has in the
development ecosystem at large
moving from there
another aspect of javasci i wanted to
show
was actually this
so first of all here we have a very
simple animation uh defined in javas
with julia
and that animation
looks like
so this animation was created using
julia it's very simple just four simple
shapes and if we go back and examine the
syntax for javas we can see that it uses
basic julius syntax
but then as this is pi data and i did
want to show how julia can also
interoperate
with python allow me to show you the
python translation of using javas
so as you can see we're actually able to
directly use the package called pi julia
within
python itself to be able to call the
javis package from julia to create not
only um
you know
that bridging between the two languages
we can actually create pep8 standard
python code written exclusively in
python implementing the underlying
library of julia and again just to
highlight
this animation is both created by julia
and python so
just to highlight how that
interoperability works i just want to
demo that
and also just how the syntax when we
examine them together
almost look exactly the same granted
that there is some differences between
python and julia
and then for my last example that i
wanted to highlight
was also this so within
uh within the julia ecosystem
unlike uh
well within the julia ecosystem we do
have notebooks such as pluto uh such as
jupiter but we also have notebooks
called pluto notebooks these pluto
notebooks do not have a global state and
instead are actually
uh reactive such that there is only one
single global state and they interact
with each other whenever a new cell is
created or run to update the state at
large
in this case
if we scroll down
we can actually see that initial
animation i showed at the beginning
bound to widget through which then we
can actually walk through different
aspects of the animation
this makes developing with javas very
easy and very fun as well so you can see
your
creations on the fly
and also to highlight using pluto
notebooks
this animation here or rather this
notebook here was created by
our maintainer giovanni um
pichetti
and he uses javas to actually illustrate
the
motion and physics patterns of a simple
pendulum
using both javas embedded within pluto
notebooks
and actually
in the future right now this is a
prototype example to show how java can
be embedded within pluto notebooks and
deployed onto the web we can actually
use
twitter notebooks directly on the web
themselves interact with them as you as
i saw showed you earlier with the code
and let's continue to mess around and
tweak them to actually understand what
these notebooks might be trying to show
you
now getting back to
our presentation
javascript as i mentioned has many
different qualities it has an
action and object relationship which is
a different paradigm from other packages
such as i3 and java or man m and python
it integrates into the julia ecosystem
such as with graph networks or learning
algebra applications
and furthermore there's multiple
different workflows that you can use
with java's you can have you can use
jupyter notebooks pluto you can even
live stream animations being created in
real time to a local area network or to
the web
our next steps for javas is to continue
to build out julia animator's
organization
java's right now is currently monolithic
but we're hoping to break it out into
different packages specific to domains
such as mathematics graphs or physics
which are shown by the animations on the
right
and as i said before or as actually
logan mentioned
we believe in julia that bridge building
is immensely important and that's why i
wanted to highlight also how you can
actually interoperate javis with python
using julia
and this could be the same for also r or
matlab
and now finally just to highlight at the
end
uh how can you get involved with
status so let me go ahead and take you
to a couple places where you can look
the first place is the javascrile do it
which is an open source messaging
platform that you can look at
here we have a community of over 85
developers
uh and users of javas talking about
their ideas how they can use javas and
where they can improve uh the package so
far
in package ecosystem additionally we
also have
your javascript documentation which is
located here
the tutorials that you'll find on javas
on the java animators website were made
with extreme care as we know
animations can be difficult to make and
we will make that as easy and painless
as possible for you as beginner to
java.jl
just to highlight here's one of my fav
personal favorite tutorials showing how
to use layers within javas to go for
something like this
it's something as complicated as an
animation that looks like an andy warhol
painting
so coming back to the end of our
presentation
i just want to acknowledge uh some
obvious inspirations such as
grant sanderson of three blue one brown
daniel schiffman of the coding train in
i3
chromolyn a legend in the julia
community for animation visualizations
and our google summer of code students
particularly our sharma and our
maintainers both harsh as well and
giovanni pichai
and finally a huge thank you to all the
contributors for bringing javis to what
it is today
without your support we would not be
where we are so thank you all so much
for your time and we look forward to
seeing your animations
oh thank you jacob and it was an awesome
presentation so uh i specifically
remember we invited viral b shah for
paid keynote back in 2019 and it's so
fun to see that julia is doing so well
and there's so many beautiful packages
coming out of it and i just i also
there's also fact that i would like to
emphasize that data is not about python
is all about best data best best data
science practices you can do using julia
or python and any other languages that
you use for data science it's not just
specific to python so every every
language is basically welcome here
so yeah uh
now next week do we have john with us
john cox
um so my name is john i'm an
undergraduate student at emory
university and i'm excited to be sharing
my project that i've been working on for
the last 10 months um
using generative adversarial networks or
gans to produce elliptic curves based on
rank
so i'll start out with just a little bit
of background on elliptic curves so an
elliptic curve is the set of solutions
of the equation y squared is equal to x
cubed plus ax plus b
and uh below are two graphs of two
different curves which is uh pretty
typical of what they might look like
so there's a lot of features to talk
about elliptic curves but um since it's
just a lightning talk i'll just skip
over most of it
but um
most interesting things that optic
curves are used for are in cryptography
and also some outstanding um
theoretical math problems that use their
properties
so the property that i use for
my project is the rank of the curve
and
to keep things simple you can think of
the rank as a measure of the size of the
solution set for a given curve
so some properties about the rank is
that there's no simple
pattern for knowing
what the rank of a curve is given its
coefficients
um this conjecture that theoretically
there's no limit to the rank of an
elliptic curve
although the highest discovered rank is
currently 28.
and nearly all curves of rank zero and
one
um
just about fifty percent are rank zero
about fifty percent are one and almost
zero percent are greater than one
so knowing this about rank i thought it
would be cool to do my project on
creating a deep learning uh
network that produces elliptic curves of
specified rank
the current model that i'm working with
right now
is trying to produce elliptic curves of
rank one
so to do to do this we use the gan model
and um
the gan model is a clever way of using
two neural networks
to produce fake data that imitates real
data
the first neural network is the
generator that is able to generate
uh fake data
the second is the discriminator that's a
binary classifier that decides whatever
data is fed to it is real or fake
so what this looks like in my project
what the architecture looks like is
random noise input is sent to my
generator which is able to create fake
um
curved data
and then i also have a data set of real
curve data
and these are randomly sampled into the
discriminator which is then able to
produce whether it's real or fake
then through um training these neural
networks through back propagation and
updating all the weights and biases the
goal is to be able to produce a
generator that's able to create
fake data that's
undecipherable from the real curve data
so hopefully all the data it can create
is of rank one curves
so the way that i
am implementing this project is through
pi torch um
in a jupiter notebook and i use this
because it's very simple
to update all the different key
parameters of these neural networks
and um
i'm just going to give a quick demo of
what
this looks like in a notebook
so i have these um classes of the
generator and determinator
set the parameters
and then i train the data and here i
just have a simple data i should train
in a few seconds
um you can see through each epoch that i
run that the losses are updating
and then um after it's done training i'm
able to see what curves were produced by
the generator
and um
and you can go through and check the
accuracy of these curves that's actually
what i'm working on right now with
updating parameters of
all these models but um
yeah hopefully i'm able to produce other
curves that
but the ultimate goal is to produce
curves of high ranks since those are
considered rare
right now i'm just focusing on producing
any curve of any specified ring
and
that's where i'm at right now with my
project uh thank you for listening all
right uh thank you john uh it was a
lovely presentation and if any if you
have any questions with john you can ask
him over the slack
uh so we'll move on yeah thank you
uh so we'll move on to our next
presentation do we have timo metzger
with us
yes hello
all right
i really like the i really like the
background and the steam hex plots
i love hex plots all done with bokeh of
course so that's uh what i'm going to
talk about basically what is new in
bokeh 2.4
i'm timo metzger i'm a technical writer
at make path that's a company from texas
specializing in geospatial data science
and i'm also a core team member for
bokeh
and what i will be talking about in the
next few minutes is basically just a
very quick introduction for the key
features of bokeh what is bokeh to those
who haven't used it extensively yet and
then some highlights of bokeh 2.4 and
then maybe a little uh preview of what
we're thinking um for bokeh 3.0 which
will be the next big release that we're
working towards
so first off what is bokeh well in a
nutshell bokeh is an open source python
library that allows you to create
interactive visualizations that run in
web browsers so a python thing that
allows you to do interactive stuff in a
web browser i think that's that's pretty
exciting and of course these things in
the web browser are javascript powered
but the nice thing about bokeh is that
you don't need to write any javascript
code yourself you can define your entire
interactive visualization directly in
python
and so let's look at a
few
quick examples here
so of course that is all directly from
the bulkhead documentation interactive
meaning you can do
all the things in your browser you can
zoom you can select things
directly in the browser you can do
all the standard visualizations and
plots that you could think of
even some more
unusual designs like this one here works
pretty much the same
and of course it also all works in
notebooks so you have all the same
interactive functionality directly in
notebooks
and remove that
and then another cool thing is that you
can not only do plots or individual
plots you can actually combine plots
and interactive elements to create
entire dashboards again all of that
defined in python and then run in a web
browser as an interactive dashboard
there's also several libraries on top of
bokeh like panel and holoviews that make
these things even easier to use
so let's briefly go back and look
how bokeh actually
does that
there so bokeh is actually two libraries
there's the python library um where you
define your visualization and and do all
your data things and then there's a
javascript library called bokehjs that
runs in the browser
so whenever you do something
on the python side whenever you define
models plots
visualizations on the python side this
information gets serialized into json
and this json data then gets used by
bokehjs in the browser to render the
actual thing you can see
bokeh also has a server component that
basically keeps the data between bokeh
js and the browser and the python code
synchronized so whenever your user does
something in the browser you can
basically through callbacks handle that
in python as well
so what's new in 2.4 well very exciting
is latex
you can now use latex in several places
in a visualization so those are all
screenshots of bokeh plots we can see
right here um that's been a really long
requested feature and thanks to some
funding from the shan zuckerberg
foundation we've finally been able to
make that happen
this actually took quite a lot of work
in the background and we had to change a
lot of how bokeh actually handles text
in general so there will hopefully be
also some other nice text features to
take advantage of all that work that
happened in the background
so you can see here latex works on axis
labels
it works on axis ticks and it works on
div widgets
and we will have latex support on
hopefully many more elements in our next
releases
another thing that we
worked a lot for the 2.4 release on
are the docs our documentation and among
many things in there we
rewrote and restructured most of our
contributor documentation
so
that also ties in nicely with what logan
talked about a little earlier so we not
only have information about how to
contribute to the code base we also have
lots of information on how to contribute
in other ways like
working on the docs or how to ask us
questions how to get in touch how to
file issues how to work on the github
repo so definitely everyone check that
out and we also have those nice colorful
boxes now that make it really easy i
think to quickly find the right
information if you want to contribute to
bokeh so for example we now have a very
detailed step-to-step guide to setting
up a development environment so you can
as you can probably imagine because
bokeh consists of a python component and
a javascript component this can get a
little complex to get all that working
together correctly so we now have some
very good step to step step-by-step
instructions for that also the testing
suite for bokeh of course is a little
more complex
because of all the visual elements the
interactive elements so there's also now
some
new documentation on how to run all
those tests locally
and then there's of course a lot more
we now have improved svg exports that
also was a much requested feature
especially for visualizations that have
multiple plots in them now they export
beautifully to svgs and you can use that
as a basis to create pdfs or
do other things that you couldn't do
with just a png export
there are several improvements to the
bokeh server that component that i
mentioned earlier that basically keeps
things between python and the browser
javascript in sync
um you can now use base maps from xyz
services and map plots and we now also
have wheels on pi pi finally
so for more details on what is going on
in 2.4 and what is new there i'd also
recommend you check out the blog
blog.bokeh.org
that has a very detailed blog post on
what is new in 2.4
so looking ahead just a little bit um
there's lots of things that we're
working on for bokeh 3.0
of course lots of improvements to the
existing code base and maybe some major
focuses i would say would be on
improving compatibility with existing
web frameworks things like angular so
things that run in the browser
improving accessibility
that is a big
topic currently
for the plots themselves so for the
output bokeh generates itself to improve
accessibility there and also for our
docs and website
and another thing that we're working on
is
for example better support for webgl new
ways to
uh actually put bring our output into
the browser
now all of these fun ideas uh bring us
to the last question for this little
lightning talk how do we get there how
do we get all those nice new things well
of course with your help bokeh is an
open source project and it only exists
because
of people who contribute
there are many things
how you can help coding and non-code
related
you should definitely check out our new
contributor docs and our website um
our github repo and there's also a
bokeh sprint that we're doing on
saturday so since you're all here on pi
data i hope you'll all uh join us on
saturday that is 1600 to 200 utc
you might have to convert that to
whatever time zone you're in and we
already have our little slack channel up
here on the pi data global slack so if
you can find us at ok sprint that would
be great we can just chat about bokeh
visualization in general and of course
it would be great if you join us for the
actual sprint maybe help out with a
little issue or two or yeah just chat
about bokeh in the state of
visualization
thank you very much and i think we may
have maybe a minute or so for questions
otherwise i'll talk to you on the slack
channel all right thank you timo uh it
was a nice presentation and i really
look forward to the uh sprint and i'm
i'm sure like there are other
maintainers also joining us for the
springs right correct yes we'll be four
a total of four of us will be awesome
that would be great so yeah uh please uh
have a chat with tim on slack and the
slack channel that we have created book
experience and if you have any questions
ask them and ask them ask him in the
slack
thank you
yeah thank you very much uh do we have
our next speaker
okay so thank you very much
i'm going to talk about using ipython as
presentation tool
and the question is why do we want to do
that hold on i just lost something
and ipython is interactive
you can run code
and it's much more fun than these boring
slides i pretty much sure that i lost
some of you to twitter by now so stick
with me we're going to move to something
much more fun than these slides and this
is ipython
right so ipython
it's interactive um a lot of people are
not questioning what is going to happen
now is it's a live demo how many
mistakes i'm going to make here
and it's also very focused on what i'm
doing there's not a lot of distraction
going
so right you could do the
the usual stuff of python which is run
some code
and show the results and
you can do discovery and have
interaction with the audience
which i find it's more fun than showing
slides with prepared
answers but ipython gives us more it
gives us magic
so
i can do
this for example and then
people can look at the code it is nicely
highlighted there are line numbers so
you can discuss which lines and i can
say on line 20 i define x and now let's
look at the shape of x
and i also have the code
inside
ipython so it's both showing us the code
and i can play around with the code it's
much more interactive
so how can i do this uh soc and these
are the magic commands that you can
mickey uh i think we can't see our
terminal we are only seeing the slides
right now
i think you're supposed to yeah i think
i think now we would be able to see
yeah so
as i said uh you can do the uh
these calculations of
uh seven times
or you can run soc and then you can see
the code you can have line numbers
discussed about line 20 and then look at
x.j
or
y.j and i have the code here so people
can see what's going on
so what is this src this is a magic
command i wrote to ipython
the double question mark at the end is
an ipython extension to show the source
of things including magic commands so i
can do this magic command and see what's
going on
sometimes i would like to display some
text so
i can use the built-in cat command for
example to do some kind of a poll how
would you rate your titanic experience
and see what's going on but you know
this is just text it's a little bit
boring so
why not
do it with a bit more style
and then i can have colors and other
things and again
this is just an alias for glow it's a
command line utility that renders
markdown
on the screen
i can also say you know what you have
only 10 seconds to answer this
um
paul and this is uh is going to run an
interactive timer so ipython gives you a
lot of things to do interactive widgets
with
very little
effort by what you're doing and this one
is using a library called tqdm which
shows progress bars both on terminal and
ipad
if you want to
do something
counting down and there is a utility
called trim down
and i'm going to say that i want to use
the
dot font and i want it to speak in
english
and i'm going to give it seven seconds
and now it's going to count down
and even speak and even change the color
wow so combination of ipython a lot of
nice utilities what about images so if i
want to look at images one thing i can
do is i can use the system command so
i'm on linux xdg open but you can use
also
open on mac or start on windows and
for example i'll show people the captain
of the titanic
this is edward smith
but
i can also do
um
icat
sorry the magic icat
and you can see it on the screen and
there are two options to do that one is
to use the terminal i'm using which is
called kitty which has this ability or
you can use the qti python to show the
images there as well
by the way making mistakes when you're
doing live
codes is part of the fun so
get used to it you're going to
do it sometimes we want
big text
so here we have two utilities one is
called figlets and the other one is
called toilet
uh so if i'm going to
echo ipython
through
figlet
this is going to show ipython
in a big text
um turret has its own phone and turret
has set of fonts so
i can do it like this and this is a
different form
another thing we do a lot also is show
math equations and here
i don't have a really good solution
but using unicode right so in unicode
you can do a lot of stuff with equations
there are
superscript and there are all the
letters and many other things you can
use but
it's not as good as latex so
the other option is to generate the
images and i take and show them as issue
and finally it's always
good to remember that you have this
um nice utility called calce
uh which is always a heated parties uh
which is a cow cow that
is talking
uh
so that's it i hope
i convinced you to try out by python to
give a talk next time it might be more
interactive more fun it will cause
people to wonder how are you doing all
these things
and thank you very much
oh thank you miki and
this is this is like a perfect lagging
talk like you know showing your hacks
and tips what you do and you know to
make your makeup work more productive
and
things like that and like thank you for
thank you for covering this and uh i'm
sure you have joined the slack right
yeah but uh the thing is this is uh half
past midnight my time so ask me
questions there i will answer tomorrow
awesome awesome yeah yeah please take
care of the time zones uh you know
so uh yeah uh
this is there so so this was the last
lagging talk of the first day of first
leggings vlog lagging talks a lot and we
are we are basically at the time
so
i think yeah
we can ask your questions and if there's
anything during the conference that you
would like to
there's any doubt or any questions you
can find me on the slack i'm by the name
sanketh verma and feel free to connect
me and with my
teammates over at the slack and yeah see
you around